you can't worry about what the experts
say we just hope that they stick once
again stick to their word we want them
to sound dumb at the end like stick to
your guns if you were calling us
pretenders in the beginning call us
pretenders now call us pretenders the
whole time because you gotta you gotta
be that way you don't get to go
hindsight is 20 20 with this every year
you know what i mean just stick to your
words stick to eat guns we're a terrible
team we're not we don't have enough
talent we're just you know on a
rebuilding year et cetera et cetera
whatever the case may be whatever your
word was please stick to it
that's richard sherman's weekly
post-game rant i assume he's only going
to do that as long as they keep winning
it probably rings a little hollow well
stick to your guns baker mayfield didn't
shake your hands stick to them then i
mean you said
come on
the video
that's the hell of the evidence that
we've seen
stick to your guns he didn't shake your
hand i mean that's just a bunch of bs
richard there's nothing i could say more
than that no we've reevaluated the
situation and it's changed we think
you're awesome sorry
here's what he wants he wants to have
the easy external motivation that comes
from the perception of disrespect so if
everyone is saying the 49ers are great
and i've moved them up to number two in
the power rankings
coming up later in the program it's hard
what do you do and eventually you're
going to be like tom brady after a
playoff game saying nobody believes in
this and everybody's going to say what
the hell is tom smoking everybody
believes in you somebody spiked his
avocado ice cream i mean but if you can
convince yourself of it see that's what
it's easier to get yourself lathered up
if you believe that everyone thinks you
stink once you improve you can't say
well no everybody who thought we were on
a playoff team is prohibited by law from
changing their opinion that's just such
a stupid and lazy take but i understand
why he's doing what he's doing yeah he
wants it all to say they stink and
continue to pick against them so they
have that motivation yeah no i
understand that too and players are
always going to look at you know
anything to kind of get them riled up
give them a little extra motivation yes
but the reality is yeah we do evaluate
people i mean yeah you know sometimes
you think people are nice people and
they end up being murderers and then we
don't just go no they're nice still i'm
sticking to my guns they're still nice i
don't care about the murder no they're
not they murdered somebody and we were
fooled okay and maybe we were fooled by
this that might not have been the best
example but that's all i had for you
okay yeah i mean it that kind of took a
turn yeah
you know
you could just say you can think
somebody's really nice and then it turns
out they're a jerk yeah well you're
talking about me i thought you were
talking about me until you went murderer
and then i'm thinking does he know
something i don't know yeah well i don't
know i just i guess oj popped into my
head more than anything sorry all right
but either way all right go ahead what's
your grievances okay uh my my first
grievance is this uh uh i'm gonna go to
the dallas cowboys here okay because the
jones family has rewarded two players on
their football team and done the right
thing by them and gave them the
financial security for the rest of their
life and guys like ezekiel elliott and
demarcus lawrence all right and i'm
gonna sit here and i mean i we banged on
the table especially for ezekiel elliott
okay and i'm going to hold him to the
standard and i like ezekiel as a
football player and everything but right
now mike i mean i can't look at ezekiel
elliott and say he's the cream of the
crop in the nfl at the running back
position you know i watch that cowboys
jets game last uh last week on film
yesterday okay there was some runs in
that game where i go um if that's dalvin
cook if that's christian mccaffrey if
that's leonard fournette um who else am
i missing in that conversation nick
chubb who i just watched the game before
and i went damn nick chubb looks like
he's in fast forward compared to ezekiel
elliott there were some runs in the game
this past sunday there were 15 yard runs
20 yard runs where i go if those were
the other guys they're 70 yard
touchdowns and you're being paid big guy
like you're the best running back in
football you know hey anybody can run
through a big hole and make 15 yards 20
yards you're getting paid 15 million
dollars a year because we expect you to
like not let the one guy on the field
who's left to make the tackle from being
a 70 yard touchdown to just being a
20-yard gain that demarcus lawrence the
his inability to sac if you look to the
dallas cowboys right now i'd go oh they
made robert quinn the highest paid
defensive lineman in the hit in the
history of football or the highest-paid
defensive he's he's been phenomenal oh
wait it's the other guy that i don't
really see show up right now so yeah
that would be my grievance if you're
gonna ask for more money then you're
gonna get scrutiny when you don't
perform and you're being paid like the
highest guy in football like you've done
uh with kirk cousins before and things
like that
so what's your grievance your grievances
ezekiel it isn't playing well so he
shouldn't have gotten his contract no
i'm not saying that you're right what is
my grievance my grievance is that when
you get paid a lot of money you better
perform or you're gonna get scrutiny and
uh the scrutiny has not really started
on those two so i guess i'm starting it
right now
on demarcus lawrence and on ezekiel the
guys who got paid and if anything you
know that hurts dak prescott because if
you've got your two other guys that
you've given market value to and they
dip
at some level the cowboys are going to
say
maybe we should just let this play out a
little bit more with dak prescott
because maybe if we give him a big
contract the same thing is going to
happen although it's different people
there's different circumstances if you
feel like you've been burned by making
the big investment and you're not
getting the return on it and that's all
these guys want they want the return on
their investment they don't want to pay
for past performance they want to pay
for current and future performance and i
guess your point is it's on the player
at that point to just you got to do it
the owner of the family they gave you
the money now you got to make them look
good and look right and perform at that
level and they're not and if you want to
know why they're three and three those
are two big reasons i would go that's
why
all right so my grievances i had to
spend the time for my grievance
explaining your grievance and i didn't
have time to get to my grievance yes
that's my greeting okay good deal with
it all right let's have enough we have
another hour of pft
live still to come we'll be back with
all of that
right afterwards
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports